- [Reporter] This is a spike protein.
It's what gives the coronavirus
its unmistakable look
and scientists think it may
be the key to why new variants
of the virus are becoming
more transmissible.
- A new study by the
CDC is raising the alarm
on the coronavirus variant
spreading across the country.
- The fast-spreading COVID-19 variant
first found in the UK
is now evolving in a way
that could make existing
vaccines less effective.
- [Reporter] New research shows
that the more transmissible
variant from the UK,
called B117, will likely
become the most common version
of the virus in the US.
- The big concern is that, with
more transmissible variant,
you have more cases and
you have more chance
for superspreading events
and epidemic surges
which overwhelm our healthcare systems.
- [Reporter] Here's the science
behind why these new
variants are spreading faster
and what this could mean for vaccines.
(soft music)
Like other viruses, when
the coronavirus replicates,
small genetic mistakes,
or mutations, can occur.
- You can be almost certain
that as long as there's a lot of virus
circulating in the community,
there will be the evolution
of mutants because that's what viruses do.
- Many of those do nothing.
Some of those actually
confer a survival benefit
for the virus to transmit more
effectively, for instance.
- [Reporter] Abraar Karan
is a global health physician
who has been studying
the coronavirus pandemic.
- And so, as it does that,
it has a better chance
of spreading to new hosts
and continuing to
replicate in those hosts.
- [Reporter] Karan says this
is likely what is happening
with the new, more transmissible variants
appearing around the world.
Recent research has shown that a number
of these new versions of
the virus have mutations
that affect the spike protein.
Take a look at this
model of the coronavirus.
You can see each spike protein
is made up of three identical
parts known as protomers.
These protomers have the
ability to change their position
from closed to open, affecting how easily
they can bind to and infect human cells.
- You can visualize it like a flower.
So you've got petals on the outside,
the really obvious thing that you see.
There are three of them.
The three of them have
to bind to the receptors.
- [Reporter] Jeremy Luban is a virologist
who studies the coronavirus.
He explains that when
the protomers are down,
infection is more difficult.
But when these parts are up
and open, it's much easier.
In the first version of the coronavirus
that originated in China in 2019,
these protomers usually
had a closed shape,
which may have made it less transmissible
than some more recent
versions of the virus.
This is another view of a spike protein
that helps to show where
these mutations occur.
In the winter of 2020,
one mutation, known as D614G, emerged.
It appears in this region
of the spike protein.
This mutation made it
more likely for the spike
to have an open shape,
increasing the virus' ability
to infect human cells.
Soon after the mutation emerged,
variants that had it took over.
- So by June, pretty much all
the viruses around the planet
had this change, this mutation.
Our belief is that it
supplanted the original virus
because it was more transmissible.
- [Reporter] Luban thinks
this is what is happening
with some of the new variants
that are emerging around
the world as well.
- In the United Kingdom,
that variant really expanded very rapidly.
It was first seen in September
and now it's the dominant
version of the virus
circulating in the United Kingdom.
Does indeed appear as if
the same thing happened
in South Africa.
- [Reporter] Another element
that affects the spike
protein is antibodies.
These are proteins that defend the body
against the coronavirus
by blocking the ability
of the spike protein to attach to cells,
which prevents the virus from infecting.
Antibodies are produced
by the immune system
in response to infection or vaccines,
and so far, the new coronavirus variants
scientists are worried
about all have mutations
that affect the spike protein.
Here are some that
scientists are focusing on.
The first is called N501Y,
which was first detected
in the variants from
the UK and South Africa
in the second half of 2020.
This mutation is located in
a region of the spike protein
known as the receptor
binding domain, or the RBD.
This is the main location
where the virus attaches to
human cells and infects them.
The N501Y mutation seems to
be helping the virus bind,
which could help explain
the higher transmissibility.
The second mutation
that scientists are
focusing on is called E484K.
It's found in variants
from South Africa and Brazil
and reduces the ability
of certain antibodies to bind to the RBD,
which helps the virus'
chances of infecting cells.
- What the antibody
recognizes is the shape.
If you're playing with
blocks and you have triangles
and circles and you have to fit them
into the appropriate holes,
you can't fit a circle
into a triangular hole.
It's analogous to that.
If the virus then changes
so that it's no longer a triangular hole
but it's a circular hole,
then the antibody will no longer fit.
- [Reporter] Scientists have also found
that some of the new coronavirus
variants have parts missing
in a region that comes off
the side of the spike protein.
This is known as the N-terminal domain.
- Some of those mutations
are removing surfaces of the protein
that other antibodies bind to.
If the virus mutates that
surface or deletes it,
those antibodies are
no longer going to work
to block the virus.
- [Reporter] Scientists
say this may help explain
why current vaccines may
be becoming less effective
against some new variants.
This is why experts are urging caution.
- Variants are gonna continue emerging
and we need a public health
strategy that addresses it.
We have to focus on
getting better ventilation.
We have to get people
better personal protection;
better, higher-grade masks
that can filter better;
we have to test; we have to trace;
we have to isolate the
fundamentals of epidemic control.
- [Reporter] And Karan
says that while vaccines
should still be effective in
preventing severe illness,
a booster variant shot may
be needed later in the year.
- They work extremely well right now,
right, With Moderna and
Pfizer 95% vaccine efficacy.
They will start to work less well
against some variants into the future,
but that is to be expected
and that is why vaccines
will be a major part
of COVID control for
the foreseeable future.
- [Reporter] Experts continue to emphasize
the importance of getting vaccinated
along with other strategies
to keep transmission low
and stop the spread.
(soft music)